foreign
's YouTube channel in this session we
will learn about how to change a data
type of a column in a table using SQL
now before we begin I would like to tell
you guys that we have daily updates on
multiple Technologies if you're a tech
gig in a continuous hunt for latest
technological Trends then consider
getting subscribed to our YouTube
channel and don't forget to hit that
Bell icon to never miss an update from
Simply learn now without further Ado
let's get started with our one point
agenda that is
how to change the data type of a column
in SQL now let's take a quick look on
the syntax we will be using to change
the data type of the column and SQL
so this is a syntax we'll be using so we
will be using the alter keyword table
keyword and table name so Alta is the
keyword which will help SQL to
understand that we are trying to modify
something and we are selecting the table
by offering the table name and then we
have the modify keyword which will help
SQL to understand that we are trying to
modify something and we are modifying
the column name from the table selected
and we are modifying that particular
column to a different data type which
will be specified over here in place of
data type keyword right so now that we
are clear with the syntax let's proceed
and execute the command and change some
column data types now we are on the SQL
workbench previously we created an
employee database in simply learndb and
we will be using the same table here so
we will be typing use simply learndb
so that we get access to the simply
learn DB and the tables we have there so
let's select all
employee table
column let's execute this
so there you go we have the table on our
screen and let's quickly describe the
table using the desc command
and this will give us the data types of
each and every column in our table now
you can see we have pin code in the
format of worker so let's try to alter
or modify this particular pin code
column from worker to integer since it
only saves the numbers right so our
Command for that was alter
table
table name which is employee table
modify with the keyword
modify the column PIN code
to integer
semicolon now let's quickly run this
command
and there you go the command got
executed successfully let's try to
describe the table once again
and there you go now the PIN code was
earlier mentioned as worker and now it
got changed it to integer now that's how
you alter or modify or change the data
type of a column in a table in SQL with
that we have come to an end of this
session and if you have any queries
regarding any of the topics covered in
this session or if you require the
resources or the commands that we used
in the session please feel free to let
us know in the comment section below and
our team of experts will be more than
happy to resolve all your queries at the
earliest until next time thank you stay
safe and keep learning
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here